you know
you know when it's midnight and you're
in the bar and you you get the sense
that you know the bar is going to close
in 90 minutes and you think
you know not enough people have seen me
yet and maybe we should go to another
bar some more people can see me
yeah i feel like podcasting is like
is like that for me not enough people
have heard my thoughts and i feel like
my mom raised me to be a giver she
didn't want me to be selfish
and i had these thoughts that i think
that i think could be a waste if you
didn't give it to the world people seem
to really enjoy them
yeah no i enjoy well while i've probably
been on my best behavior today on on
this episode of the podcast
so if you want the uh the uncensored
unfiltered
uh the full spectrum that the force of
nature is john clark
you go to you go you go to the podcast
you funny enough
i think you're drinking throughout most
of the podcast yeah yeah
tequila so they only last like an hour
because you seem to like
uh i'm guessing that you just lose it or
like it's like cinderella turns into a
frog or
whatever one of the things i'm learning
is um
sometimes you have great conversations
when you're drunk and sometimes you
don't like i was
i i went into it with the uh right drunk
edit sober mentality
yes hemingway hemingway yes but
turns out that uh
sometimes you don't have that much to
edit when you're super shit-faced
and so uh i've been scaling that back a
little bit
and what do you mean exactly by that
like where does it go wrong when you're
drunk i'm curious about that because
uh it gets you especially when you have
a personal relationship with the person
that you're talking to
rather than trying to put some ideas on
display for other people to hear and
maybe talk about
you wind up just having like a
conversation with your bro about inside
jokes and things like that it's like
it's not that interesting no one wants
to like watch you know
go to a bar and watch two people at the
sitting there getting drunk and talking
to each other is different
than listening to uh like strong
discourse
yes one interesting thing as a fan of
joe rogan i'm a fan i've been a fan of
joe rogan for a long time and he has
his friends over a lot right and there
there's a
aspect to those three four five hour
conversations that i really enjoy
there's a magic to those
i think he taught the world that those
kinds of long-form conversations can
work the what you forget
is joe rogan is a comedian his friends
are also celebrities like
they know what it's like to be on the
mic they know
there is a challenge to actually having
your friends on the microphone
totally like they're they've never this
is the first time they've been on a
microphone yeah and
that's actually what you've been doing
which is a very interesting experiment
and uh you find that some are more
awkward than others like they're trying
to find like
what do i do with this kind of thing why
why do you not talk to strangers why did
you go with people that you're
actually no so the simple answer is the
people that i selected are both
interesting and i thought would be good
at talking
but then i noticed the thing you just
mentioned my buddy paul did the first
one and paul's a wild man
and if you went out with paul he can
talk about a bazillion topics
to a certain to to a significant uh
level of depth right he's got a good
understanding and he's got a unique
perspective on a lot of things
um and i think
he was the first guy invited on my
podcast
and it was almost like
he was on a little bit less than natural
about it and then by the time he
loosened up with some drinks
he was it just we were all shit-faced
there was a there's a phase shift though
totally yeah totally and so he's gonna
come back
on and he'll be more comfortable with it
and uh and it'll probably be awesome
because he's a great person to talk to
um i had my friend dave on who's a
restaurateur and a musician
that that one will be released pretty
soon but yesterday i had a guy on who
you might really enjoy listening to
who's a friend of mine his name is mark
clem
he's an endurance athlete and he's been
compared
he's been called the white dave goggins
and um
he talks about like those comparisons
and what he hates about it
and the various events and stuff and
he's just a guy who's just always kind
of like natural and like i knew he'd be
great to get on the podcast
and um so i started with friends
who i thought could handle it and who
also are just really interesting people
and uh and i i did it so that i could
also establish a level of comfort
because it was a new thing for me
and they i knew that they wouldn't
really give a what i was doing and
be like hey this is cool i'm going over
jc's house we're gonna drink some
tequila and talk there's just gonna
be a microphone there this time
i mean it's amazing what you're doing
the freedom of it i mean you're not
currently doing any advertisements or
any of that kind of stuff you're just
exploring your voice this is one of the
mediums that you're just
trying it out my 11 subscribers know
what i'm about you're 11 subscribers
it's in the double digits
you